all right welcome to my first video
do
hey what is up guys mkbhd here
thank you i figured i should make a
video saying thank you uh the tech
community here on youtube is awesome
fact hands down and you don't even have
to look very far to see that i really
believe that the tech community on
youtube is a special breed of awesome uh
and i'm really glad to be a part of it
not just the people who are making
videos but the people who are watching
tech videos too uh all one big tech
community but i really just wanted to
make a video saying thank you
thank you specifically you this is the
first video i'm uploading to over a
million subscribers on youtube kind of a
ridiculous number uh and i've read all
of your tweets your facebook messages
google plus comments uh youtube comments
um i can't possibly reply to all of them
in fact i would break twitter api if i
tried uh but trust me i'm reading
everything you guys write and that
really extends to all the videos i've
uploaded here obviously i can't reply to
every comment on every video because i
wouldn't have time to make more videos
or go to class but uh the point stands
that a lot of the feedback you guys give
me on the videos positive and negative
it helps a ton and that is the number
one thing that helps make my videos
better
including my drive to intentionally try
to make much better videos i've said it
in interviews i've done and in a lot of
the messages that i've sent you guys who
have asked me about it the number one
goal i have for this mkbhd channel here
on youtube is to upload videos that i
would want to watch uh in an order in a
way that i would want to watch them and
that million subscriber number i guess
means that a million other people have
signed up to watch what i upload next
and that's pretty crazy i've learned so
much from doing this and i have so much
to learn and it helps that i love every
second of it uh but really we're just
getting started like i don't know if you
guys realize there is so much that still
has to be done i mean there's the mac
pro review the ps4 review the xbox one
review just to name a few and the tech
never stops the new phones the new
tablets computers they never stop and my
interest in it will also never stop so
uh i just i guess i just wanted to say
thank you uh if you're a subscriber if
you're one of the million people uh
thank you uh and i guess now more than
ever it it's this is really just the
beginning and when i say i'm just
getting started like this is really just
the very beginning so more than ever
thank you for watching and i'll talk to
you guys in the next video
peace
you